Ron you there morning I what up playa
I miss see your little room there with
all your a nascar [ __ ] it's still here
hasn't gone anywhere by the way is it
true you went and got a haircut yeah
it's a day before they closed the barber
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
would you do that I mean the guy the guy
was all done he had gloves and mask [ __ ]
you know yeah and the blue water in the
combs it was protected your hair is that
important to you no I just well I just
wanted him you know I don't know how
long is it's gonna go on so I figured
you're gonna close the barbershops so I
went got a haircut real quick do you get
paranoid about getting this thing I mean
you 70 years old um no I try not to
think like that hey he only coughed on
me twice and Steve's in my hair once all
I'm saying is I'm trying to understand
people who are in quarantine themselves
you're gonna get it dude I got a report
Ronnie went shopping went to the bank I
went to I was in um I was in the bagel
store for like five minutes
just getting some bagels that was it
meaning like you went into the bagel
shop inside and there were other people
in there it was two other people and how
far apart of you we're far apart I stay
far away I was like are bagels an
absolute necessity
Gary people go shopping what the [ __ ] he
is supposed to do that was in there for
five minutes buying bagels yeah catch it
in five minutes yeah but you weren't you
were in the supermarket with 50 other
people I was in a baby store with two
people there but run you're gonna do you
breakin my balls for you had one in the
supermom just saying that you don't need
bagels like that's one less than Beatles
I know you wanted what you wanted and I
just make one point to you Ronnie
because I'm always trying to explain
this to you going to the supermarket is
a risk you're right but it's an you got
to do it right the bagel shop is one
more risk you didn't need you should
have gotten the bagels at the [ __ ]
supermarket so you have one less
horrible
hate to interrupt all of us yeah but we
have limited time with an a-list
celebrity who's been listening to all of
them talk about rod obviously ronnie is
invoking the New York bagel rule where
you go to the bagel shop and you could
put twenty nine people into the bagel
shop you gotta have a bagel you can't
have a supermarket bag okay wait pain
the mentality of someone who will not
quarantine themselves I think that
people what we need to do is we need to
alienate everybody who is not quarantine
those people that don't get it we have
to a lien ate them they're outcasts
there you can't deal with them and plus
it tells you something about them could
the sacrifice you're being asked to make
is when you're thinking about it
relatively modest you know you're going
to do this so we can all get back to
work we can all defect school we can
forget about death and illness but we
can all get back to a normal life a life
I think we all appreciate